well I was an eight-year-old kid
watching the first Apollo moon landing
way back in nineteen sixty-nine and
there was something about that moment
that really stuck in my head I'd always
been interested in space and flying and
I was building model rockets and model
airplanes but something about that
moment I can remember like it was
yesterday watching the Apollo moon lunar
lander approach to the surface of the
Moon and then later watching Neil
Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin take the first
steps on the moon and something that
that day just started the dream for me
that hey I want to be like those guys
you know all my friends wanted to be
astronauts we all played astronaut
outside you know and and so I'm sure my
parents and teachers probably thought oh
well that's cute you know but and even
for me it was something I never forgot
it was in the back of my mind even while
I was going to school but it was until I
was a university studying engineering
that I thought what do I really want to
do and I kind of came back to that and I
said well you know this degrees that I'm
trying to get are going to qualify me to
apply and so that's what I did after i
finished my or after i was getting my
doctorates that's when I first applied
to NASA
well the minimum requirements to apply
to be a NASA astronaut are is a least a
bachelor's degree in science or
engineering so I was getting that
covered and also you have to be in good
health which you know I was in great
health so i didn't have trouble passing
the medical but that's the basic
requirements you know so it's pretty
broad I mean NASA selects from a broad
range of people in my class alone there
were 23 of us and there were several
folks from the military you know the
test pilots flight test engineers but
there are also medical doctors research
engineers like myself we even had a
physicist and you know people like that
so really it's just you know the
recommendation that I give people who
are interested is study something that
you're interested in that you have a
passion for because that then you're
going to do your best and that also
qualifies you to apply to be an
astronaut